Okay, we should be live.
Or getting ready to be live.
Awesome.
All right.
Okay, we should be live.
I think we're live.
Let's check it out.
Cool.
We are here.
All right. Hey guys we're here we're live.
Let's get this going.
Okay.
It should be good to be able to watch that.
I'm going to start tagging everybody.
Go from there. Can you still hear me here?
Yeah.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you.
Okay.
Let's get everybody.
So we're going to tag everybody and let people kind of pop on
here.
And we'll wait till we have three or four people.
Sometimes you only have five or six people, but.
We'll just see what we get today.
Yeah.
Then we get started once people start popping on.
Okay.
I think we're good to go.
So,
I don't know if you've ever done one of these,
but if you watch both,
there's a huge delay between what you and I are doing and then what
people.
See or respond with on Facebook. So it's kind of a trip for me.
Sometimes.
So.
Yeah.
If I seem like I'm saying something that was like something you and I
talked about like five, 10 seconds ago, it's because.
Okay.
All right. We've got a few people coming on.
We're going to be, um,
kind of helping you guys out and getting a jumpstart on transferring
and, uh, we're not transferring, but, uh,
Setting up search campaigns like we've talked about.
Um,
So that's kind of going to be what we're doing today.
we'll let a few more people get on board here and we'll get started.
Obviously this video will stay on Facebook.
So there shouldn't be a problem with that.
Um,
Everyone will be able to get it.
We're trying to set up a simple search campaign for you guys
to be able to use on your one pagers.
And we're going to try to make it.
Um,
As kind of fast and simple as we can.
We're probably not going to, uh,
dive deep into a lot of the explanations.
We're just going to kind of show you how to do it.
So you could do it on some of yours.
Um,
And we'll take a few questions as we go.
But the goal is to kind of have this up and running.
Um,
let it sit there on the Facebook group and then you guys can kind of
jump in and take a look at it.
Uh, right now we, we've done some longer formatted ones, um,
that are being edited and kind of chopped up to make it a little,
uh,
easier to digest.
And then what we'll do is as these things roll out and we get more
questions and stuff,
we'll see where we need to explain more and stuff like that.
So we'll probably do like a more polished, uh,
version of everything at some point. Um,
but we want to get you guys going on with stuff and at least give you
something to work with. And then we'll just keep,
we'll just keep polishing it up, making it easier for you guys. So,
uh, all right. Well, with that, um,
we'll let our special guests come on. Francesca, are you there?
Yes.
I don't know how special, but I'm here.
All right. And for those that don't know, Francesca is, uh,
why don't you go ahead and introduce yourself and, uh,
credential speak for yourself.
Yeah. So I've been working with Nick for,
I'm going to my fifth year and I'm running like the agency side for
him pretty much.
I'm sure some people have talked to me on the application as well.
So when they first applied,
I'm the one that answers those as well for anyone that,
you know, has joined since, um, April, I would say.
Some people shouldn't know me or at least I've heard my voice.
Okay. Good. Good. Um, so anyway, so just for you guys, um,
so Francesca kind of runs, uh,
most of Nick's ads and stuff like that, like she said, she's kind of the, uh,
she's the one who makes sure that place runs and keeps going. Um,
so we've been working together for probably like the last five, six months.
And, uh, we've been testing a lot of stuff, seeing what works,
what's not working.
And so that's what we're doing today is to try to show you guys some,
um, simple search campaigns. So with that,
we've about seven people on we're going to go ahead and start rolling.
And we're going to see how well this goes. So,
so bear with us. And, um, we, to save some time,
we've preloaded a few things. Um, I'm just going to touch on them.
They're pretty simple things that I preloaded.
It's just so you guys don't have to watch me typing and things like that.
So it's just to save a little bit of time on your end.
So you don't have to watch typing and things like that. Okay.
Um, like that reminds me before we get started here,
I forgot I got to live this up to give me one second, guys.
I just want to get this going here.
Okay.
Sorry. I forgot to bring up the keyword planner.
All right.
Yeah.
So.
Let me just, let me just plug this in real quick.
Okay.
And I'm going to show you guys what I'm working on. I've just, uh,
like I said, we're just trying to save some time and I'm just going to show
you how to, how we do some things and just have to set some certain stuff
up.
Okay.
I think we're ready to go here.
All right. Cool.
All right.
So I'm just going to show you how to save some time.
Okay.
I think we're ready to go here.
All right.
Cool.
All right, everybody.
So we're going to go ahead and get started here.
Let me go ahead and share my screen.
I think away we go.
All right.
Oh yeah.
You see everything now.
Okay.
All right.
So here we go, guys.
We are going to hop in and, um,
Set up a search campaign today for you guys.
Um, there's two different types of main search campaigns.
Um, there's one called, uh, like a call only, like a call ad.
And then there's the standard, like webs, uh,
website traffic or like a, like a click to call ad where somebody clicks on
your website and then they click over.
Um, and do that. So we're going to, um,
we're going to set up a call only ad because that's a more simple one to
set up. It's very similar as you guys will see in more training,
but it's a, it's an easy one to set up.
Um, and it gets the phone ringing fairly fast.
So that's what we're going to show you guys today.
Um, with that, I'm going to, I'm going to get on my phone real quick.
Uh, or Francesca, can you see the Facebook group on your end?
Are you able to monitor that?
I am not on Facebook. Let me, let me go in real quick.
Okay. That way, if you see some comments come up or something since.
Yeah.
Okay.
If you see any comments, just let me know.
Okay. So guys, so what we're doing, so we're in the, uh, MCC account here.
Uh, we went up and we set up, you guys,
this is all the same as the trainings we went and we set up a new sub
account.
Um, so we're setting up, uh,
this is a client that reached out to you guys.
You guys didn't do a prospecting for it.
This is an inbound person that came to, uh, Nick's, uh,
agency and wants them to help them get leads for duck cleaning in the
New Orleans, uh, area, um, in region.
So we're going to set up that campaign today for you guys.
And you guys get to kind of watch how this is going to go.
So what we did is we set up the sub account and we go to,
we click on that and now we're here in this screen.
So that's the same as the training. You guys get to this spot.
Now you want to set up a new campaign.
So click on new campaign.
Okay.
Since we want to focus on a call only ad.
We're going to use, take advantage of the leads.
We're going to select leads.
Call.
And then we're going to click.
Right here at search.
Okay.
We're going to do website visits.
It's going to ask.
For our.
Our website.
Um, do you know if the, uh, has it been HTTPS yet?
Does it have that SSL on it?
Yeah.
Let me try that.
Okay.
And then we're going to go here.
And it's going to give us these four different, um,
lead conversion goals.
And we're going to click right here.
Phone calls from your ads.
And then I just like the name of this.
So we're just going to call this.
No.
Okay.
I'm going to ask you, do you want to focus on conversions or clicks?
Um,
You can, you can set up conversions if you want.
I kind of like clicks right now.
Um, but.
It's not a huge issue one way or the other,
but I prefer to do clicks may just be the way I was trained to do it or
whatever.
Okay. And now what we want and something for search campaigns is we
can set.
Um,
The reason for this is like,
You don't want to get into a bidding war where you're doing like $30,
like keyword clicks or something like that.
Okay.
All right.
Love you.
Um,
And sorry.
Yeah.
And then,
so what we're going to do here is we're going to go here and we're going
to set a maximum cost per click.
And you guys are going to ask me.
Okay.
So what I did is I took our top four keywords.
Um, I went into keyword planner.
So if you guys go to tools and setting.
You, you hit keyword planner.
Okay.
And I paste it in our top four key keywords here.
I set my location up for the new Orleans, uh, area.
Okay. And it's given me.
Um,
And then it's given me the low range and the top, uh, high end range.
Okay.
And you can see here, there's a pretty good, I mean, look at this one.
It's like a $15 difference between the low and the high end.
And stuff like that.
Uh, this one's, you know, from seven 50 to $24.
So, um,
they know that air duct cleaning is a very, uh,
expensive competitive niche now, especially like post COVID.
Where people are more and more into it.
Okay.
Um, so.
We're, um,
We're we're looking at this.
Um,
what we want to do is we want to be on the high end of our top of page
bid.
But because these are so, so, so, so high.
Um,
we just got to try to figure out like a happy medium for right now.
Okay. And we can always adjust it.
But kind of looking at like, I'm seeing a lot of like.
So we're looking at the top of the page bid.
Okay.
And I'm not going to go into the top of the page bid.
I'm not going to look into the top of the page bid,
but it's definitely a high end.
So I'll just go for $4.
But I look on the low end and I'm seeing, you know,
seven, eight, nine, $10, stuff like that.
So what we'll do is to kind of play it safe.
What we'll do is we'll set something.
That's a little under those really high ends,
but it's definitely way over the low end.
So for right now, what we'll do is we'll choose 13.
76.
Okay.
There's really no science behind that, but.
We're going to.
That's the maximum we're willing to do for a click. Okay.
I'm just showing you guys how you set this up.
Obviously, do we want to set up ads in New Orleans?
Probably not, right?
But this is a client that reached out to them
that wants to do business, that's already paying them.
Francesca and them know what they're doing.
They already told them like, hey, it's an expensive area.
It's going to do duh.
Like they set up a big contract.
They got enough room to play here in this space, okay?
But for you guys, if you guys are seeing
those big variations,
you just kind of want to choose something,
but you definitely don't want to be on this low end, okay?
You want to be somewhere in the middle.
If everything's equal and these are like $6, $7 higher,
what I recommend then is doing one penny higher.
That's my recommendation for that.
Okay, enough of that.
Okay, now we go here, we hit next, right?
And this is where they're going to try to trick you again.
But now we finally get to opt out of the display network.
And then they hide Google search partners
right here at search network.
So I've done this sometimes where I think I'm good
and I forget to uncheck this.
So you want to uncheck these two right here
because you only want to play on the search network now.
I don't care about these other ones, right?
We want to save, we want to get rid of those clicks, okay?
Now it's going to ask you for a location.
So we're going to say enter another location.
Now this particular client has some particular locations.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to click advanced search, okay?
And then what it's going to do is it's going to give us,
because of the towns that they want to target,
we've already kind of looked at this.
So we're going to choose radius, okay?
So we're going to do a radius.
I'm going to do about five miles
in between each of these cities.
And we can always go back and adjust this later.
So I'm looking for Gonzales, Louisiana.
And I can bump this out to more.
We're going to keep that at five.
And we're just going to kind of see how this,
how this works for us here.
Okay.
And again, we can go back later and adjust these,
but just to kind of give you guys an idea
of how we're setting this thing up a little bit in this area.
And the reason why we're doing a radius
and not like an exact city is because
when you get on the outskirts of New Orleans,
it's a little more rural,
but obviously the city of New Orleans
is going to be a lot more dense.
So we're going to choose these here.
And then, oh, it's all right.
We got the one more.
We got it.
Hang on a second.
I have to figure out the spelling of that one again.
They'll chase, no wonder why it's not.
I don't know.
All right, let me see that.
There it is.
Okay.
Now see how that kind of gets in here.
Like we can reduce that one if we find that this is too dense,
but we're going to leave it for now.
So these are going to be our main locations
that the customer wants to target.
So they actually want to kind of target
around New Orleans, which is good.
Okay, so that's how we're setting that up.
And then you want to click here where it says location.
Click here where it says location options.
The default is going to be presence or interest, okay?
This is going to show you,
this is going to be wasteful ad spend.
So we want to make sure that we select people
that are in or regularly in those targeted locations
because that's where homeowners and business owners are.
Not tourists, not people driving through, stuff like that.
So we always want to check that.
It just helps save for better click searches.
English is our language.
Audience segments, we don't need to really worry about
for what we're doing.
We want to go here and more settings.
These are the default.
So we can tweak some of these or we can leave them the same.
I prefer to let Google best optimize whatever,
like the best performing ads
instead of me having to try to control it
because it just takes too much time and maintenance
and stuff like that.
So the default is this.
That's what we want to make sure.
We're going to start today with no end date.
You can do a different schedule.
And because it's a call ad,
we're going to set that up like that
because we don't want calls coming in
like super late at night, right?
So we'll probably start it at like 7 a.m.
and we'll run these till probably,
it was almost 6.30, sorry.
And we'll probably run these till like maybe like seven.
That'd probably be a decent time.
And then that's going to be that for there.
You can see that there's obviously more settings.
These things we're not worried about yet.
So we go here.
Okay, now it's going to want to run our ad group.
It has right here, it gives us our website.
Okay, now Google is going to try to give you
a bunch of keywords in here.
Okay, when there's nothing over here,
these are considered broad match.
So we're going to go ahead and type in the keywords.
We're going to type in the quotes as a phrase match
and the brackets are exact match.
We only want to use phrase match for right now.
So to speed things up, we took the keywords
that Francesca gave us.
We went to this website called AdWordsWrapper.
Okay, I pasted my keywords in here.
I told Google to wrap it.
I'm going to go down here
and you can see the different types of keywords,
labels right here.
I'm going to go to the phrase match one.
Don't push the copy button
because for some reason it doesn't copy it.
I don't know why.
I hate when the menu moves in front of you.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe a little maneuvering.
Okay, there we go.
Zoom thing was in my way.
Okay, I'm going to copy all these.
I'm going to delete.
And then I'm going to paste my own.
Okay, so this is from our own research.
These are the ones I want to run phrase match on
and we're going to go with that.
Okay, now we're going to get into setting up our ad.
Now, because this is a call only ad,
we only get a couple of headlines
and a couple of,
oh look, it's going to give us more this time.
Awesome.
So we're just going to fill it out
with like just a few basic ones
and then just to save time here,
but you can optimize it as much as it'll give you, okay?
So we're going to go here.
We have our website.
You can kind of see that it kind of started auto-filling it,
but we're going to stick to like what we're trained on, right?
So, right, so what we're trained on is, right,
city and service main keywords.
So we're going to do New Orleans.
We're going to see if I can get,
let's see if I can get, oh, look at that, perfect.
Okay, what's the next one?
Get a hundred percent free, right?
So,
that'd be awesome, a hundred percent free.
Can you just put estimate?
Well, it's only for 30 characters, so.
Yeah, just like get a hundred percent free estimate
without the duck cleaning.
Yeah, I think that's what we're going to have to do.
I tried though, okay.
Yeah, I know.
Okay.
Dryer vent cleaning.
Let me see what I should just do this.
Okay.
Okay, so we're going to just do these four for now.
We'll come back another time and we'll fill this out.
We want this to kind of get up to like the good
or the strong range eventually.
So the descriptions, right,
we're just going to stick to what the training,
it still works, right?
So we go here, we copy that.
So we're going to do,
we're going to play with that a little bit.
So we specialize in.
And like Jeff said,
you want to complete as many headlines as they give you.
We're just doing it quickly.
So we're not wasting everyone's time,
but you want to, obviously if you're doing it yourself,
same with the descriptions, you have four.
So we're just probably going to fill out two,
but you want to complete as much as you can.
Okay.
That's probably good there.
And then we're going to do, right, we're going to do this.
Okay, and again, guys, we're doing this
because we're trying to make this right
as down and dirty as possible.
So,
I'm going to see, I think I can get,
if I can get that in, right,
I might be able to get cleaning on that.
It's in the area.
Cool.
All right.
So we're going to leave those there, okay?
Your local, affordable,
professional air ducting experts.
Okay, great.
Okay.
And then from there, like that's kind of that.
Okay, again, we'll come back in here
and we'll clean these up and add more
to increase the strength, okay?
So just for time for you guys,
we don't need to spend time doing that right now,
but we'll do that later after the live.
So I'm going to hit done.
You don't need to worry about all those call-outs
and site links and all that stuff.
We'll get into that stuff later,
but don't worry about that for right now.
Now it's going to ask for our daily budget.
Now it doesn't give you the recommendation anymore, right?
So I'm going to move us here.
Zoom so I can see here.
So what we'll do is we'll click here.
So obviously some of the clicks were like high up there.
So we're going to see what it does at $25.
We're going to see what it gives me.
So at $25, it's telling me I can expect about 22 clicks.
It's going to cost me about $160 a week
and this is my average CPC.
So that's not terrible, right?
If you're getting that many clicks
and potential calls a week,
obviously if I went up to like say $55,
it's probably going to give me,
looks like it's giving me the same results, okay?
Let's try like $75, let's just see what it does.
So that's great.
That if that's all good,
we're going to try to bump it down to 20
and see what it does, only 21.
So like, that's not bad.
Let's see if I do 15 and it tells me that's too low.
Okay, so we're going to start at $20
because that seems to be a decent amount, right?
I think anybody would be happy with
that many clicks per week for right now.
And let me move this back up here.
The optimization score at first,
don't worry about that.
That's something that I'll kind of explain in a second,
but don't worry about this right now.
It can get better if you add better headlines
or more headlines and more descriptions and things like that.
So we'll fix that later.
And we're going to do another training series
where we'll go over that,
but don't worry about that for right now.
Okay, so now we go here.
It's going to, we're going to just double check everything
that it's a search campaign.
Sometimes if you forgot to uncheck one of those boxes,
it'll tell you search display and other stuff.
We're doing leads, phone call leads,
we're maximizing clicks.
We're on the Google search network, none of the others.
We have our different locations,
our language, everything here.
All day is 7 a.m. to 7 p.m. and $20 a day.
And we're like, cool, let's go ahead and publish it.
So this ad now goes into what's called a policy review.
Okay, this will take a couple of days.
Okay, and then it should go live.
And then once it goes live,
you're going to be in this thing called bid strategy learning.
Okay, and this takes about five days.
So it takes about seven days for like the ad
to get really warmed up.
So two days to go through policy review
and then about five or six days
of like actually running to do that.
So, but this gets you up and running
and you'll get, you'll definitely gonna be reducing
those really cheap crappy clicks on YouTube,
search partners and stuff like that.
So those are gonna go away.
What you're gonna see is you're gonna see
a lot less impressions because we're only on the one network
for a handful of specific keywords.
So you should have better quality clicks now,
which is what you want, right?
We just set one up the other day
that we're gonna go back and do some filming on.
And I mean, Francesca, what was our estimated daily spend
between the two is like $50 something per day
is what we set it up for.
I know the total for like the month.
Well, I think the daily budget we set up
to be like $45 a day.
Yeah, there's two different ads and we were doing it,
but like our actual spend has been like,
what, maybe the most like $15 in a day.
So way under and they're getting way less impressions
because they're getting more quality impressions.
So the clicks they're getting are a lot more quality.
And that's a great thing
because you're not wasting the ad spend
and you're getting people that are actually looking
for your business.
So.
And yeah, and like we talked,
this ads are something that you kinda wanna keep an eye on
especially the first week,
but it's better to like have it higher and don't get scared.
Like just check in and see how much you're actually spending,
but then you can go and trim it back.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I think we covered what we wanted to cover again.
This is for a call only ad.
We'll do another one maybe next week
where we do a click to call ad,
which is the website traffic setting.
It's super similar to this.
It's just, we click another button instead of another.
It's not really a huge difference though,
but we'll set that up just to show you guys.
It's not a huge difference.
It just land differently on the platform.
Okay.
So the call only ad, just FYI,
like that only like,
you will probably not see a lot of like desktop impressions
and or like tablet impressions.
It really only works on devices
that people can click the call.
So like I'm on my Mac,
I could probably get one
because I can FaceTime call out of it if I click.
But what's cool about that is that
it's definitely going to show more on phones.
And that's where most people are calling from anyways, right?
So anyhow, just wanted to throw that out there
and that should help you guys get your phones ringing.
So Francesca, do you have anything
you think we needed to review or cover?
No, I think you did awesome.
The only thing that was kind of weird for me at first,
so I kind of want to throw it out there so people know.
And what we mean by having like a call ad
and then a website ad,
they're all going to be under the same account.
It just means like we set, we go more into depth,
a little bit more advanced than a smart campaign.
And we set up the call ad
and then a separate one under the same account
for the actual website.
Well, doing a smart campaign,
you're letting Google do that for you pretty much, right?
Jeff, is that?
Uh, yes, yeah.
He just kind of makes it into a big mixing bowl
and we're trying to have a little bit more power
and then make it more detailed.
I don't know how else to describe it, but hopefully.
Yeah.
Well, this gets us back to like the original setup
of like the intent of the original smart campaigns
before Google started changing the platform on people.
So this allows everyone to kind of take back
a little bit more control.
And obviously just if you guys start, you know,
try not to play around with the framework too much
if you've not used to it
because you can easily get yourself in trouble.
So we tried to just make this super streamlined,
like click here, do this, do that, don't do that, do this.
We're trying just to keep you guys lined up
and squared away on it.
So you don't get in too much trouble.
That's definitely a potential issue with this.
So hopefully this is helpful
and you guys can be able to use this
for your own campaigns now.
With that, if anybody has any questions on anything,
type them into the Facebook.
I'm not really seeing anything,
but I'm gonna hit refresh here
because that could just be my bad.
So stand by.
But if anybody has any questions on anything,
please type it into the chat
and we'll give you guys a second here.
I'm not seeing anything.
Are you, Francesca?
No.
Okay.
We'll give it a minute.
We'll pin this, right?
So people can watch and pause it while you get started
and then we'll do the website one soon.
Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, we'll get into that.
Okay, someone, oh yeah, should we put negative keywords?
You can, you don't have to right away.
There are some that you want to,
like you go like cost, how to,
depending on what you wanna do,
like cheapest ideas.
It's probably like the main ones off the top of my head
that you wanna load in there first.
And then what'll happen is like after a handful of days,
you'll start seeing, right?
Because there's three different types of keywords, right?
There's broad match, phrase match and exact match.
Broad match is trash, we want that out.
Exact match can be good,
but they have to type in exactly like what you put in there.
So phrase match is good because like,
let's say I'm doing like landscaping.
Well, if I put landscaping as a phrase match,
then it could be like anything landscaping
will show an ad in that region.
So there might be ones where like you see something
and you just take like that one word before or after
and you throw that into the negative keyword list.
But it's definitely a lot easier to manage
than it was with the smart campaign.
So in theory, that should keep a bunch of the legions
from clicking into our ads
since most of them are coming from desktop and those.
Like I think you're talking about like Angie's
and thumbtack and all them.
They will probably be able to still click them,
but it will probably reduce it.
But those guys are spending millions of dollars
to beat the spammers and all the protections and all that.
So hopefully it'll reduce it a little bit,
but it's just part of the game now, unfortunately.
All right, are there any other questions?
I know it's the delay, huh?
I don't see anything, but we'll see.
Yeah, all right, we'll just give them a minute.
Like I said, there's like, there's this weird delay.
It's taken me a while to get used to.
Okay, here we go.
So Alex says, we have an ad we set up
under the Google smart campaign.
We received 520 clicks,
47, almost 48,000 impressions.
Yeah, it's six months of the cost.
We received no calls and of course, we,
yeah, it's just starting to turn and move on.
I would try to redo it,
but if you're getting that many clicks
and really low CPC like that,
I would bet that you probably have the budget
set too low for the smart campaign.
But what you can do is just pass the ad
but what you can do is just kind of pause that.
You probably have a lot of the good stuff already loaded
like your keywords and your locations
and your headlines and descriptions.
And I would just create a new search campaign
and then just set up the call campaign with the leads
and just set that up.
And you'll probably notice a significant drop
in impressions.
You're gonna notice a significant drop in clicks.
However, you're going to get a higher CPC
but you're gonna get better click-throughs.
Got it, thanks, you're welcome.
Okay.
Sorry, I need some weird people emailing me right now.
Okay, Francesca, do you have anything else to add?
No, I don't.
I think this is a good start.
It'll get everyone to be able to set them up
at least this first part, like the call ad
and then we'll go more in depth into the website one
and the webpage one, sorry, and everything else.
Yeah, definitely.
Like I said, everybody, next week we'll go in here,
probably use the same one and we'll set up the one
for the click to call ads,
which is the website traffic thing.
It's literally pretty much the same process.
There's just a couple of small tweaks on it.
We just wanted to show you guys the fast, easy way
to get this going and get on it.
So I don't really see a lot of people on,
not seeing a lot of other questions come in.
So we're gonna end the call here.
And once this kind of uploads and processes,
we'll go ahead and make sure it gets pinned to the top
or put in the files or something like that.
And we'll do that.
So Francesca, thank you as always for your expertise
and helping out.
Thank you, Jeff.
Hopefully this helps.
I think it will.
I think a lot of people are gonna be pretty stoked on it.
Like if they implemented it tomorrow,
by the time the weekend's over,
they'll be out of policy review.
And by Monday, Tuesday, they should start seeing some calls.
And just like we've seen on the one we set up for you,
that was just a little over a week ago now,
like eight days or so.
Like did you notice yesterday,
like a lot more clicks and calls yesterday?
We got one lead today.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
So we're already seeing,
like we can watch the uptick already.
Like as it comes out of that policy review
and that learning strategy,
you can start seeing it kind of hit its groove,
which is really common to the same thing.
That was the same thing with the smart campaigns, right?
It has to go through a few days.
That's why we always say,
hey, let things go for a couple of weeks.
With this stuff,
there's gonna be a little more maintenance off the top,
but it's a simple thing.
And we'll go over that maybe next week as well.
So, cool.
All right, everybody.
Since we don't see anything,
you guys are welcome.
We'll pin this up
and then you guys have any questions, reach out to us.
All right, take care.
Thanks again.
Thank you.
All right, bye.